president Trump enters into wild battle
with the media Attorney General Jeff
Sessions is out and the left's
intersectional rage cannot be stifled
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show too much news too much news okay
there's no way to cover all the news but
we will do it and we will do it with
aplomb alacrity and finesse wash us but
first we first have to talk about the
fact that the Democrats have retaken the
house which means that a lot of the
positive policies Republicans have
enacted over the past two years could be
stymied well the Democrats start to
obstruct what effect would that have on
the dollar on stocks and other unknowns
that could impact your savings
what is your plan can you afford another
hit to your retirement like the last
downturn when the S&P dropped 50% you
need to hedge against inflation and
hedge against uncertainty and
instability by diversifying your
portfolio with some precious metals gold
is a safe haven against uncertainty in
my savings plan is diversified yours
should be to the company I trust with
precious metal purchases Birch gold
group right now thanks to a little-known
IRS tax law you can even move your IRA
or eligible 401k into an IRA backed by
physical gold and silver look back
historically when the bottom falls out
of everything gold is always worth
something it's to safeguard savings
Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews and a plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau contact Birch
gold group now it's request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals that comprehensive 16-page kit
reveals how gold and silver can protect
your savings it can legally move your
IRA or 401k out of risky stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA if
that's something that you're interested
in doing to get that no-cost
no-obligation kit go to birchgold.com
slash men that is indeed birchgold.com
slash pen so we begin today with a
couple of news updates from around the
nation a couple of stories that are
deeply upsetting the first story is
obviously this mass shooting that has
now happened in Thousand Oaks California
so this is pretty close to where we are
obviously you know mass shooting
anywhere in the United States is
horrifying but a mass shooting that is
close to you feels a little bit more
immediate in this particular case the
gunman who massacred 12 people at a
country-music bar in SoCal on Wednesday
night has been identified as an
ex-marine we have a policy here on the
show that we do not actually identify
the name of the shooter but we'll give
you details that you know motive
the open fire on the borderline Bar and
Grill in Thousand Oaks at 11:20 p.m.
this person had been cleared by mental
health experts after an incident in his
home in April
sheriff's revealed on Thursday morning
so once again somebody had a brush with
the law and the brush with the law was
not enough to end with this person being
prohibited from firearms ownership or a
gun ownership California it does have an
A rating from the Brady Center for gun
control it is considered the most gun
controlled state in the United States
we've had a multiplicity of mass
shootings in California in the past few
years we had one in Santa Barbara we
have this one we had the one in San
Bernardino we've had a bunch of mass
shootings in the past five years alone
the the killer killed 11 people inside
the bar one of the first cops on the
scene he shot also before taking his own
life survivors from the shooting said he
looked like he knew what he was doing as
he repeatedly fired his legally purchase
Glock 45 handgun it's also worth noting
is that he was using a handgun he was
not using a so-called assault rifle so
all of the talk about banning assault
rifles would have done nothing to stop
this shooting either this piece of human
filth through smoke grenades to confuse
the crowds while he started shooting
folks people were hiding mini pool
tables and using bar stools to shatter
windows to escape the first police
officers arrived at the scene three
minutes later and then the shooter shot
one of them multiple times before
shooting himself by the time SWAT teams
arrived he was dead his body was found
in an office inside the bar he started
the sheriff's sergeant who was shot
later died in the hospital he was Ron
Heelys a 29 year veteran in total 13
dead 11 killed in the bar the sheriff's
sergeant and the gunman and again this
guy is a former Marine who lived in
nearby Newbury Park who apparently had
mental health issues in April this year
deputies were called to his home amid
reports of a disturbance who's acting
irrationally and was irate so police
called in their mental health specialist
they cleared him decided against having
him committed and left him at the home
it is unclear when he bought this he had
no criminal history except for a minor
traffic infraction a neighbor told ABC
he was known to suffer from PTSD the
woman who did not want to be named said
she had no idea what he was doing with a
gun he had apparently modified his
weapon to hold more rounds so again gun
laws in the state of California not
being effective the handgun was designed
to hold 10 rounds and one in the chamber
the weapon did have an extended magazine
on it that he's either obtained
illegally or had modified illegally so
that he was able to hold more rounds in
the in the magazine obviously a terrible
story it will drive more conversation
about gun control even though as I say
California is extraordinarily heavily
gun controlled and the notion that more
gun control prevents mass shootings like
this is simply not true in a country
where there are already something like
four hundred million guns in circulation
in the United States in other news
Supreme Court Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg who was 85 broke three ribs in
a fall she apparently fell in her office
at the Supreme Court tests showed she
fractured three ribs on her left side
she was admitted for observation and
treatment broken ribs are incredibly
painful
obviously we pray for her recovery and
that she should be in good health but
her health obviously has significant
ramifications for the future of the
Supreme Court were she to retire from
the court for example then that would
have a massive impact on the future
president Trump would still have the
ability to appoint some replacement who
presumably would be frontrunner Amy Kony
Barrett it's a little bit early to say
that but she's gonna be okay according
to medical reports right now obviously
when older people fall there's obviously
a lot of speculation about what happens
after that because very often declining
health begins with fall sort of like
this is not the first time though the
Ginsburg is fractured ribs in June 2012
she fractured two ribs in a fall
she didn't disclose the injury to the
public until months later she hasn't
missed a day on the court despite a
couple of rout rounds of cancer as well
as a fall in the past she says that she
wants to serve on the bench until she is
90 she's now 85 so she's hoping to
outlive or at least stay on the court
past president Trump's tenure on the in
the White House so there is that is your
quick news update one more note I should
add just about the gun laws and and
state homicide rates there is no
correlation between mass shootings and
gun laws there is no correlation between
the state homicide rate and state gun
laws people who have tried to draw this
sort of correlation are doing are doing
so in statistical error that is
important to note at the outset okay so
the big news yesterday and still this
morning continues to be president
Trump's press conference that he held
yesterday it was a wild and crazy press
conference he took something like 60
questions from various members of the
press and he had a
a number of things to say about the
midterms what he had to say about the
midterms kind of fascinating so here's
what he had tweeted out directly after
the midterms president Trump he tweeted
out to any of the pundits attacking
heads that do not give us proper credit
for this grade midterm election just
remember two aids big news
so Trump was ready and raring to go
immediately upon the outcome of the
midterms now you know giving presidents
from credit for some key Senate
victories in swing states I think is
appropriate he also gets the blame for
Republicans alienating an enormous swath
of the suburban vote which ended with
the Democrats taking districts like the
Georgia 6th district remember there was
a special election in the Georgia sixth
District just a few months back when
John Asaf ran against karen handel Asaf
lost despite a lot of money pouring in
well karen handel lost the seat a couple
of nights ago so obviously suburban
Republicans got just walloped in large
part because the unpopularity of
President Trump President Trump then
sounded off about what Democrats are
gonna do in the future here he said if
the Democrats think they're going to
waste taxpayer money investigating us at
the house level then we will likewise be
forced to consider investigating them
for all of the leaks of classified
information and much else at the Senate
level two can play that game
obviously yeah everyone knows that the
Democrats are going to investigate the
president and as far as they possibly
can president Trump kind of levying
threats that the Senate is going to
investigate or that he's going to use
the executive branch to investigate not
ideal but expected and then president
Trump said they said in all fairness
Nancy Pelosi deserves to be chosen
Speaker of the House by the Democrats if
they give her a hard time perhaps we
will add some Republican votes she has
earned this great honor which is high
levels of troller II from the president
well then he did his press conference
and his press conference yesterday was
basically that there are a few themes
theme number one was I'm awesome I love
me and fantastic so here as president
Trump yesterday talking about how
awesome he was in the election and again
this is somewhat justified by the Senate
results it is certainly not justified by
the house results but here was the
president praising himself there was a
big day yesterday an incredible day and
last night the Republican Party defied
history to expand our Senate Majority
while significantly
expectations in the house for the
Midtown and mid-turn year okay so part
of that is true part of that is not it
is true that the Republican Party defied
history and expanded their Senate
majority that was expected based on the
polling data and based on the fact that
Democrats were running a lot of
vulnerable seats in purple to red states
the Republicans did not significantly
beat expectations in the house you know
how I know that because I predicted to
the number how many seats the
Republicans were going to lose in the
house and that was based largely on the
data that were available so Republicans
did not beat expectations in the house
it was a bad election for Republicans in
the house it was a good election for
Republicans in the Senate and that has
to do with various constituencies it has
to do with the red states getting redder
and the blue states getting bluer but
according to President Trump it's all
about President Trump now yesterday I
advanced a theory and my theory is maybe
the most controversial theory at all of
all and that is that President Trump
well he is not a generic Republican the
electorate treats him like a generic
Republican he gets precisely the vote
percentages you'd expect from a generic
Republican he is treated by the press as
they would treat a generic Republican
except more so the president may act
like he's out of the box because he is
out of the box but that does not mean
that the response to him is out of the
box in fact it is very much in line with
Republican Democrat breakdown all the
way up till Barack Obama Barack Obama is
a sort of statistical outlier not
President Trump a president Trump has
invested interest obviously in some of
the media in suggesting that all of
politics revolves around president Trump
effect which I do not actually think is
borne out statistically but this leads
President Trump to suggest that every
candidate can be adjudicated the quality
of that candidate can be adjudicated
based on how close they were to
President Trump so yesterday in what can
only be described as pretty classless
move the president gets up at this press
conference and he rips into a bunch of
Republicans in swing districts and he
says that if they'd only embraced him
more closely than they would have won
their seats here he was literally
mocking other Republicans who lost their
seats who he could have used you know in
places like the house everyone's doing
that on the other hand you had some that
decided to let's stay away let's stay
away they did very poorly I'm not sure
that I should be happy or sad
but if you'll just find about it okay
Carlos Q Bella mike coffman too bad Mike
Mia love
I saw Mia love she called me all the
time to help her with a hostage
situation being held hostage in
Venezuela but Mia love gave me no love
and she lost too bad
sorry about that Mia and Barbara
comstock was another one I mean I think
she could have won that race but she
didn't want to have any embrace for that
I don't blame her
but she she lost substantially lost
Peter Roskam didn't want the embrace
Eric Paulson didn't want the embrace
then in New Jersey I think he could have
done well but didn't work out too good
Bob you can I feel badly because I think
that's something that could have been
won that's the whole things it just goes
on and on president Trump ripping into
his own party members who didn't want to
associate with him because they were in
purple district or in blue areas does he
really believe that the the solution
there was more cowbell that if Barbara
Comstock had brought in Trump she would
won that race and if Mia love had
brought in Trump to a blue district in
Utah that that would have shifted the
race of course that's untrue but this is
sort of the myth of Trump that's been
created in the aftermath of the myth of
Obama the myth of Obama was that Obama
had radically shifted American politics
permanently the myth of Trump is that he
broke that radical shift the reality is
that Obama was a statistical outlier
because he was uniquely amazing
candidate in many ways bad president
good candidate President Trump all he
did was sort of allow the reversal back
to status quo ante which is good I mean
that's great but but the idea that Trump
is some sort of magician with electoral
votes is is just not supported by the
evidence I want to talk some more about
president from press conference then we
will get to the big with the big hubbub
of the day which is of course Jim Acosta
who loves that dude some Jim Acosta
first let's talk
about how you can save some money so
these days it is tough to get people to
agree on practically anything like
legitimately anything but there's one
thing we should all be able to agree on
saving money a good thing which is why
you need a honey it's a free shopping
tool that automatically searches the
internet for the best promo codes every
time you buy something online you know
you used to have to search around on the
internet for promo codes for particular
products or particular websites not
anymore
now when you go to honey all you do is
you sign up and then it automatically
runs and then fills in the codes for you
when you're shopping at places like
Amazon eBay j.crew Walmart Best Buy
Groupon and more it works on all of your
favorite sites it is indeed that free
shopping tool that automatically
searches the internet for the codes that
save you cash honey has already saved
listeners of this podcast an average of
twenty six dollars and thirty four cents
we've used honey in buying our instant
pot we've used it that's not marijuana
that's like the pot that cooks things
really quickly we've used honey and I
use Amazon all the time I mean I
legitimately don't go shopping anymore
all I do is shop online because I'm like
my wife was when she was pregnant all I
do is when I have to go shopping I just
won't move I'll just buy stuff online
oh honey has saved me an inordinately
because of all that honey is the
money-saving shopping tool everyone can
agree on get honey for free right now at
join honey calm slash Ben has join honey
calm slash Ben honey is indeed the
easiest way to save money while shopping
online go check them out join honey calm
slash Ben okay so president Trump
continues in his press conference so
team number one of his press conference
was I'm awesome
and everyone who did not sufficiently
embrace me loses because I am a magic
magic man and that was that was team
number one team number two was Democrats
if you start going after me and you
start trying to leverage me and I'm just
not gonna make deals with you and this I
think is relatively fair like I don't
think that Trump has any obligation to
make deals with Democrats I think in
fact that Democrats antipathy for
president Trump will prevent any
deal-making from taking place which as a
conservative is a comfort to me I don't
want the president making deals with the
Democrats and bipartisan deals tend to
be very bad for the country this is a
general rule so President Trump says he
says that basically he doesn't want to
work with Democrats if Democrats don't
want to work with him if they do want to
work with him then he's happy to work
with them but he is not going to make
deals with them well they decide that
they're going to crack down on his tax
returns
for example so here's president from
talking about that they want to do
things you know I keep hearing about
investigations fatigue like from the
time almost from the time I announced I
was going to run they've been giving us
this investigation fatigue it's been a
long time they got nothing zero you know
why cuz there is nothing but they can
play that game but we can play it better
because we have a thing called the
United States Senate and a lot of very
questionable things were done between
leaks of classified information and many
other elements that should not have
taken place now people are very upset
about President Trump for for saying
that he that partisan investigations
will take place on a responsive basis
I'm not sure why they're upset about
that it's pretty obvious that partisan
investigations are going to take place
on a on a partisan basis that's that's
what Democrats have been doing okay then
Trump moves to his that let's let's get
to the the actual meat of the matter so
the meat of the matter all of this went
by the wayside because President Trump
is in this knock-down drag-out fight
with CNN and there's been going on since
legitimately he was campaigning and CNN
has acted awfully the worst reporter on
the CNN team by a fairly long shot is
Jim Acosta as I said yesterday find you
somebody but who loves you like Jim
Acosta loves Jim Acosta I mean that dude
loves Jim Acosta every every possible
arena in which Jim Acosta can show how
much he loves Jim Acosta he does so I
mean Dubai's himself flowers takes
himself out for dates I mean he the
other day bought himself an engagement
ring and then he told himself that he
couldn't get engaged to himself because
that's still illegal but someday in the
future love will be known as love I mean
Jim Acosta loves Jim Acosta in any case
Jim Acosta decided to use the
president's first press conference since
the midterms to grandstand because today
attending and why and Jim Acosta has a
microphone and things went sideways so
here is the exchange that is making the
rounds between President Trump and Jim
Acosta I will explain where it got
controversial visually if you can't see
this that you demonized immigrants known
as electrons right want them I want them
to come into the country but they have
to come in Legally you know they have to
come in Jim through a process I want it
to be a process and I want people to
come in and we need the people you're
here you're wait you know why we need
the people - because we have hundreds of
companies moving in we need the people
your campaign had an ad showing migrants
climbing over walls in it for it but
they weren't act they're not gonna be
doing they weren't actors what no it's
true do you think they were actors they
weren't actors they didn't come from
Hollywood these were these were people
this was an actual you know it happened
a few days ago and they're hundreds of
miles away though they're hundreds and
hundreds of mile away that that's not an
evasion honestly I think you should let
me run the country you run CNN or and if
you did it well your ratings let me ask
you what you're seeing now and what
you're about to see is a White House
intern kind of pops up and she goes to
grab the microphone from Acosta she
tries to get the microphone from Acosta
by reaching over his left arm twice and
then she reaches under his left arm and
his left arm either falls or or pushes
down people are suggesting that a cost
is trying to force her away I don't see
that here what I see is that they they
come into contact but it doesn't look to
me as though he's like trying to
actively push her arm away or anything
like that and he says excuse me miss as
he does it so I don't think that's the
controversy it goes like this he kind of
she sits down again the exchange
continues and then Trump continues to go
off on a cost I calling him a rude and
terrible person because it's a hoax are
you that's enough put down the mic mr.
president are you worried about
indictments coming down in this
investigation
mr. president I'll tell you what CNN
should be ashamed of itself having you
working for them you are a rude terrible
person you shouldn't be working for CNN
I think you're a very rude person the
way you treat Sarah Huckabee is horrible
and the way you treat other people are
horrible you shouldn't treat people that
way go ahead Peter go engines defense
I've traveled with him and watch them
he's a diligent reporter who bustles I'm
not a big fan of yours either so I
understand to be honest so let me ask
you a question if I can you repeatedly
fart you are the best
mr. president you repeatedly over the
course of the gist sit down please
well when you when you report fake news
no when you report fake news which CNN
does a lot you are the enemy of the
people go ahead mr. president over the
course out okay so a couple of things
can be true yeah well as you know I do
not like it when the president says that
CNN and even when their report fake news
are the enemy of the people that's
that's not language that ought to be
used about people in the United States
enemy of the people most they're actual
terrorists but with that said you know
the when the president is ripping on Jim
Acosta Jim Acosta deserves every rip
that he receives there everything the
president says about Jim Acosta about
how he's rude to people and how his
grandstanding and about how he's
attempting to to you know push himself
at the expense of all the other
reporters in the room all that's right
well this broke into the open because
the White House then denied Jim Acosta
his hard past while a hard past is
basically a security clearance it says
that you don't have to get checked for
security every time you walk on to White
House grounds
so last night about 8:00 o'clock Jim
Acosta tried to go to the White House to
do his report from outside the White
House they said we've revoked your hard
pass you can't come in here is that
completely inappropriate no I think Jim
Acosta is a bad reporter not only is he
a bad reporter I think what they should
have done is they should have said
listen there are certain procedures in
this room the procedure is that once you
ask your question and the president
answers your question
we are done and if he doesn't want to
answer more questions from you he is
under no obligation to do so nor is he
under an obligation to hold up the
entire show while you sit there and rant
at him that's not a thing that has to be
done so I think the best possible
solution by the way it would not be a
ban Jim Acosta it would be to just not
allow Jim Acosta to ask a question in
the White House press room anymore first
of all I think a lot of these press
conferences are waste of time I think
the amounts of new information receives
at these press conferences is nearly no
it is basically grandstand
TV nonsense but with that said Jim
Acosta can be both a disgrace to two
things can be true ones one Trump his
language on the press can be wrong too
Jim Acosta can be a disgrace to his
profession who should be immediately
replaced forthwith by CNN both of those
things can absolutely be true well in a
second we're gonna get to CNN's response
to all of this plus the overblown
response of the of the White House a
little bit a little bit I mean they're
they're right that cost is terrible but
they're wrong in other aspects I will
explain why in just a second first let's
talk about making your business better
when you're looking to hire the right
people for your business
try zip recruiter comm slash Daily wire
zip recruiter doesn't wait for
candidates to find you instead zip
recruiter finds them for you zip
recruiters powerful matching
technologies against thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
skills experience education for your job
and then actively invites them to apply
so you get qualified candidates fast no
more digging through piles of the wrong
resumes there's less waiting and more
hiring so if CNN wishes to replace Jim
Acosta which they absolutely should and
they should go over and check out zip
recruiter com slash daily wire when they
do then they can tricep recruiter for
free at zip recruiters comm slash daily
where we use it here at the daily wire
offices to get rid of bad employees and
replace them with better ones CNN should
do the same at super courage comm slash
Daily wire because the fact is Jim
Acosta is bad at his job but zip
recruiter can help you replace anyone
who's bad at their job at your company
and make your company that much better
by making sure that you see all the best
resumes and that they come quickly to
your desk and filtering out bad resumes
for you zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire zip recruiters comm
slash daily wear to check it out
zip recruit comm slash daily wire all
righty so Jim so Jim Acosta is then ban
basically from the press room at least
for the for the moment and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders tweets out about his
ban from the press room and she says
that that a sudden she said we stand by
let me let me find all of her all of her
tweets she said we stand by our decision
to revoke this individuals hard pass we
will not tolerate the inappropriate
behavior clearly documented in this
video okay well that's fine I mean it
okay but she also said that she said
this conduct is she said President Trump
believes in a free press and expects and
welcomes tough questions of him and his
administration
we will however never tolerate a
reporter placing his hands on a young
woman just trying to do her job as White
House intern his conduct is absolutely
unacceptable it is also completely
disrespectful to the reporters
colleagues not to allow them an
opportunity to ask a question President
Trump is given the press more access
than any president in history okay
here's the part that I think you don't
need to do
hey the idea again watching the video
the phrase put his hands on a young
woman suggests that he sort of grabbed
her yeah that's that is not what
happened
the suggestion is that he is you know
legitimately like pushing her away
fending her off or anything and I don't
see that but what I do see is Jim Acosta
being a douche because guess what Jim
Acosta is a douche and that means that
Jim Acosta
they've fair reason to say listen you're
wasting everybody's time
you're stealing everybody else's time
you don't get to act like this and still
ask questions so we're just not gonna
allow Jim Acosta to ask any more
questions because he's a grandstander
and we're not gonna do that and I was
asked yesterday by somebody at the Rabb
core some good White House correspondent
there plenty of them Jonathan Karl I
think is a good White House
correspondent major Garrett from CBS is
a very good White House correspondent
Jim Acosta is the bottom of the barrel
he just stinks anyway
CNN responded to all of this with their
usual outrage and ire this president's
ongoing attacks on the press have gone
too far ooh America is in danger because
Jim Acosta can no longer grandstand they
are not only dangerous they are
disturbingly unamerican
well president Trump has made it clear
he does not respect a free press he has
a sworn obligation to protect it a free
press is vital to democracy and we stand
behind Jim Acosta and his fellow
journalists everywhere
hey Jim Acosta go to jail Jim Acosta
doesn't have a right to a White House
press credential CNN has plenty of other
credentialed reporters including Caitlin
Collins over at the White House CNN is
not being rejected from access to the
White House Jim Acosta is being rejected
for the moment because Jim Acosta is
terrible at his job and then Chris
Wallace ripped it in to Jim Acosta and
he said this is just not appropriate he
said he embarrassed himself which is
true he did embarrass himself so the so
reporter from CNN said hey Chris at
least that Jim Acosta doesn't work for
state TV must be harder to sleep at
night also curious I can't find your
comments about how shameful it was when
your colleagues campaign for Donald
Trump the other night and that
apparently is a reference to sean
hannity campaigning with President Trump
right because Sean
an opinion host who clearly supports
president from Jim Acosta is supposedly
an objective journalist whose job it is
to elicit the truth hey Lindsey Graham
responded in the best possible way
Lindsey Graham 2.0 so he tweeted out
it's apparent to me the White House
press corps live in a bubble and the way
they're conducting themselves today will
do nothing to improve their standing
with the American people which is
obviously true Jim Lindsey Graham's take
on this correct he scolds the media
again a few things can be true at once
it can be true that Jim Acosta is
terrible at his job and be true that
President Trump
thrives on this sort of conflict and how
do you know that he thrives on this sort
of conflict because the biggest story of
the day we're now at like half an hour
into our show okay and the biggest story
of the day has not even been touched so
what was the biggest story of the day
the presidents of the United States
fired his attorney general yesterday all
anyone is talking about is Jim Acosta
right because President Trump knows that
all he has to do is ding the egos of a
couple of people in the press and then
they will just spin off into the outer
darkness for the rest of time forgetting
to ask actual questions about actual
things that are going on also I would
point out let's look at the disparity in
coverage today between President Trump
and Jim Acosta on CNN when the treatment
of Tucker Carlson last night so Tucker
who is a good guy I have disagreement
Tucker on politics that doesn't matter
at all last night
protesters went to Tucker Carlson's
house his wife was inside with their
kids and the protesters literally tried
to break down his front door his wife
had to hide in a closet with the kids
and call 9-1-1 he heard of some video of
the incidents
[Music]
[Applause]
they're chanting we know where you sleep
at night they're chanting we know where
you sleep at night
yeah that's not that's not dangerous at
all that's not scary at all just
fantastic Karlsson told The Washington
Post Corner called my wife she'd been in
the kitchen alone getting ready to go to
dinner she heard pounding on the front
door and screaming someone started
throwing himself against the front door
and actually cracked the front door his
wife thought it was a home invasion
the couple has four children none were
home at the time she locked herself in
the pantry she called 9-1-1 Carlson said
it wasn't a protest it was a threat they
weren't protesting anything specific I
had said they weren't asking me to
change anything
they weren't protesting a policy or
advocating for legislation they were
threatening me and my family and telling
me to leave my own neighborhood in the
city that I grew up in I mean that's
that is ugly ugly stuff and of course
there are apologists including the
ridiculously stupid Matt Iglesias over
at voxcom the repository of all
stupidity and again there are some
people at Fox who are not stupid I have
friends who work for Vox but if you are
looking for a stupid take Vox is a good
place to start
Matt Iglesias wrote I think the idea
behind terrorizing his family like it or
not as strategy is to make them feel
some of the fear that the victims of
Magha inspired violence feel thanks to
the nonstop racial incitement coming
from Tucker and then he said I think
this is probably not tactically sound
but if your instinct is to empathize
with the fear of the Carlson family
rather than with the fear of his victims
then you should take a moment to reflect
on why that is um
because they tried to break into his
house last night maybe that's why that
is just ugly ugly stuff from the media
but we will see how they cover things
today I have my doubts that they will
cover it in an honest way or cover it at
all we'll get a lot more about how
President Trump has never throw ever
present threat to the press but you know
me but but protests are showing up a
Tucker Carlson house trying to break
down his front door not actually a
threat to the press solid stuff okay I
want to get to the firing of Jeff
Sessions what it means what it doesn't
mean in just
second but first let's talk about what
you are wearing on your butt right now
and I'm talking about underwear cuz guys
the holidays are coming fast and things
are about to get uncomfortable between
the crazy travel schedules and awkward
family gatherings now is not the time to
be an uncomfortable underwear thankfully
there's Tommy John the revolutionary
clothing company that is redefining
comfort for both men and women Tommy
John has the most comfortable underwear
on the planet they're gracing my Pontius
right now there are the perfect gift
especially for guys who constantly
adjust Tommy John underwear sporting no
wedgie guarantee comfortable stay post
waist bands a range of fabrics that are
luxuriously soft feather-light moisture
wicking that means no bunching no riding
up so if you're still on the fence
wondering if Tommy John would be a
memorable gift think of all the
adjusting and tugging you're never gonna
have to do again or see again when you
go to Tommy John comm no adjustment
needed give the gift of fantastic
comfort this holiday season with limited
edition holiday gifts from Tommy John
Plus save 20% on your first order at
Tommy John comm / Ben that's Tommy John
comm / Ben for 20% off again these are
fantastic underwear not only are they
super comfortable and not only do they
do they feel great they also are
extraordinarily durable I mean really
wash them many many times they don't
fall apart like the brand-name stuff
that you get from the store that's
that's cheaper and and falls apart
easily go check them out Tommy John comm
/ Ben for 20% off and that makes a great
holiday gift for yourself also ok so I
do want to talk about Jeff Sessions his
firing and the intersectional rage of
the Democrats but first you're gonna
have to go to Daley wire.com and
subscribe all you have to do is go over
there $9.99 a month gets you this the
greatest podcast in the known universe
the rest of it live it's you've heard of
our mailbag on Fridays you get to be
part of the Michael modal's show live
and the rest of the Andrew Clavin show
live you get to be part of our daily
wire backstage we did a a nine hour long
edition on election night you get all of
those wonderful things when you become a
member also if you get the annual
subscription for $99 you get this the
leftist tiers hot or cold tumbler I know
you want to subscribe just do it it
makes it a great
Konica gift great Christmas gifts great
Kwanzaa gifts great Diwali gift so go
check it out right now
all you have to do is go to daily wear
comment subscribe also make sure to
subscribe over at Facebook or a YouTube
and iTunes so that you can get the show
there leave us a review at iTunes
we have great Sunday special coming up
to Sunday with John Stossel you don't
want to check that out we have more
great Sun
specials coming up in in coming weeks we
have so many goodies for you all you
have to do is subscribe go do it right
now we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
the actual big news of the day is that
the Attorney General is gone so there's
a lot of talk about how Attorney General
Sessions was in in serious trouble he'd
been in serious storm for a long time
President Trump spent an awful lot of
time ripping on him on Twitter and
people like me be like dude you picked
him and Trump every couple of weeks be
like my own attorney general though why
in the world did he recuse himself he's
supposed to be at my best friend my
sword and my shield and he was very
angry to have sessions because sessions
very early on recused himself from the
Trump Russia investigation because he
was involved in a campaign and that
meant that rod Rosenstein was overseeing
the Moller investigation well the Muller
investigation is getting about ready to
wrap we're gonna find out in the next
few weeks what is in there they're
apparently putting the final touches on
their report which will I am sure be a
grenade thrown into the midst of our
already chaotic politics so that'll just
be spectacular
I'm happy to wait to see what's in there
because I don't know what's in there you
don't know what's in there Trump doesn't
know what's in there nobody knows what's
in there but the firing of Jeff Sessions
is leading a lot of people to be very
worried they think that now the new
Attorney General is going to crack down
on all this so Jeff Sessions was fired
he did not resign his his Donald Trump
tweeted out we are pleased to announce
that Matthew G Whitaker chief of staff
to Attorney General Jeff Sessions at the
DOJ
will become our new acting Attorney
General of the United States we thank
Attorney General Jeff Sessions for his
service and wish him well a permanent
replacement will be nominated at a later
date Jeff Sessions put out a letter in
which he began by saying at your request
I'm submitting my resignation which
means that from firing him and he talked
about how he tried to abide by the law I
agree with this I always thought Jeff
Sessions was unfairly maligned you may
disagree with him on a number of issues
I do with regard to for example drug
prosecutions but that does not actually
change the fact that unlike his
predecessors under the Obama
administration he actually did attempt
to administer the law in a fair and
impartial way he was not using the DOJ
as a political weapon of the White House
nor was he acting as rearguard for the
President of the United States which i
think is good I mean he's the chief law
enforcement officer of the United States
session's ouster has created all sorts
of consternation because the because the
acting Attorney General Matthew Whitaker
is a little bit more on record with
regard to a wide variety of issues so in
he argued that Hillary Clinton should
have been criminally charged for her use
of a private email server which again I
don't see why that's disqualifying I
think virtually everyone in law
enforcement who is not a Clinton devotee
believes this but more importantly he
also commented back in 2017 that he
thinks that the Muller investigation was
overreaching in August 2017 he said
Muller has come up to a red line in the
Russia 2016 election meddling
investigation he's dangerously close to
crossing it does not take a lawyer or
even a former federal prosecutor like me
to conclude that investigating Donald
Trump's finances or his family's
finances was completely outside the
realm of his 2016 campaign and
allegations that the campaign
coordinated with the Russian government
or anyone else so this has led a lot of
folks on the Democratic side of the
aisle to be deeply fearful that Trump is
installing Whitacre specifically to
hamstring whatever ancillary
investigations spring from the Muller
investigation now we haven't been
talking about that cuz we've been
talking about midterms we've been
talking about fights with Jim Acosta the
media are easily distractible but this
is more of a major issue now I will say
there is pretty solid bipartisan support
for the idea that the mauler
investigation should simply come to its
terminus it should come to its natural
conclusion even inside the White House
people just want to let this thing go
the idea that Trump is trying to shut
down the Moller investigation is just
I've seen no evidence of that seriously
none because Muller himself has not
implied such a thing even James Comey
said that Trump didn't really try to
shut down the investigation he didn't
really do anything he said some stuff
but Trump says a lot of stuff
nonetheless Democrats are treating this
as red flag number one they are on the
lookout for bad behavior so here is Tom
Perez head of the DNC saying that this
is worse than Watergate already fact
check it is not worse than Watergate
Watergate was the the the Saturday night
massacre which was about the firing of
Archibald Cox who's a special prosecutor
that was an active attempt to undermine
into rail and investigation that is not
happening here Trump doesn't like
sessions there's no indicator that
there's been any sort of boundaries put
on the Muller investigation at all by
sessions or Whitaker when that starts to
happen then I think that we can fairly
ask what the president is trying to put
the kibosh on it but up till now I've
seen no evidence of that not gonna stop
the Democrats from alarmism of course
and a certain level this is worse than
Watergate because this area tonight
massacre he kept firing senate-confirmed
people until he found Bork who was a
senate-confirmed person to do this okay
no it is not worse than Watergate and
that's a wild exaggeration Chuck Schumer
says the timing is suspect because
obviously this is the day after midterms
and now Trump gets rid of sessions the
idea here is that by getting rid of
sessions with a Republican larger
majority in the Senate now Trump has the
capacity to put in a person of his
choosing the rumor today the rumor today
is that it will be chris Christie as his
attorney general which just okay mm-hmm
here's why chris Christie would not make
a good Attorney General I actually like
the fact that Jeff Sessions was the
earliest supporter of President Trump
not about support for president from
Jeff Sessions treated his job with a
level of seriousness befitting the
office I do not know that chris Christie
will do the same I have a feeling that
it will be more about Chris Christie
fetching president Trump's hamburgers I
am NOT a fan of the Attorney General
being the wingman for the president as
Eric Holder was for President Obama
I think that's dishonest I thought it
was dishonest when Obama did it I would
think it were dishonest if it were Chris
Christie doing it I'm suspicious of
chris Christie it seems to me that the
president should put in place somebody
with a serious legal background and the
capacity to actually treat the DOJ as
the chief law enforcement tool of the
United States which it basically is
there's Chuck Schumer saying the timing
a suspect for as much I'm not gonna say
much until I read what they said and why
I find the timing very suspect number
one
okay so meanwhile Eric Holder this just
shows the hypocrisy the Democrats Eric
Holder tweeted this out which is just in
the same he tweeted out anyone who
attempts to interfere with or obstruct
Muller inquiry must be held accountable
this is a red line in our nation of laws
and norms not subject to the
self-interested actions of one man
mm-hmm
Eric Holder mm-hmm you act i but the
face over there you yeah mister I was
holding contempt of Congress for
covering up my involvement in fast and
furious and then the president asserted
executive privilege to shield me from
prosecution
that guy and the the you
honestly it is stuff like that from Eric
Holder's and makes people go find Chris
Christie fine who cares let Trump
appoint Melania like no one cares it's
because of that the radical dishonesty
of Democrats leads Republicans to
embrace the suck as a Nancy Pelosi was
once fond of saying okay meanwhile the
Democrats cannot get over the fact they
did not sweep in these latest midterm
elections they did well in the house but
for them that wasn't enough there was
this weird idea going around among
Democrats that they were going to sweep
everything they were gonna take back to
Senate they were gonna take back the
house they're gonna win every close race
that obviously was not true the reason
they thought that is because they
thought that Obama had created a new
normal the new normal was Democrats win
all the time
they never lose and there was this new
durable coalition that was extendable
across time and space with growing
demographic groups and it turns out that
the only person who was able to put
together that coalition was Barack Obama
and then once Obama was off the ballot
then American politics basically went
back to American politics as it was
before Republicans vote for Republicans
Democrats vote for Democrats people
don't like voting for radicals in fact
there was a Sean McElwee who is a I
think he's over at salon maybe he's a
he's a very left-wing he's at the Nation
he's a very left-wing analyst he had
created a list of the eight most
progressive Democrats running I in all
eight of them lost in the midterms so
the Democrats are upset because they had
this mythical version of what the United
States was that was pretty roundly
refuted during the midterm elections
this has led to an outsized amount of
rage on the left so the chief target of
such ire has been white women hey so
this was the next intersectional group
to go as I've always said there's an
intersectional hierarchy of victimhood
if you are at the top of that
intersectional hierarchy then your
opinion means everything if you are at
the bottom of that intersectional
hierarchy your opinion means nothing and
you must shut up at the bottom are white
men followed by white women so the
women's march which is filled with
anti-semites at the top level and by the
way I have to stop here and give credit
to Alyssa Milano who did the right thing
Alyssa Milano came out and said she's no
longer going to associate with the
women's March so long as Linda Sarsour
and Tameka Mallory remain a part of the
leadership and refused to condemn Louis
Farrakhan good for Alyssa Milano and
really a little intellectual honesty
from somebody with whom I disagree so
seriously real clap
for Alyssa Milano and women's March
tweeted this out there needs to be
accountability and an honest reckoning
there's a lot of work to do white women
a lot of learning a lot of growing we
wants to do it with you
stay tuned and what the women's March
actually means is white women why don't
you think like we tell you to think
because true feminism is telling women
how to think that's what feminism is
really about not women having their own
opinions with which you may agree or
disagree but women voting as you tell
them to vote Jamel Hill used to work
over at ESPN she tweeted out 59 percent
of white women voted for Ted Cruz 53
percent of white women voted for Donald
Trump so given these numbers who is the
real face of feminism well clearly the
real face of feminism is Jamel Hill who
tells women that they need to vote how
she wants them to vote that's what real
feminism looks like and then Mona
Eltahawy I I think that's sort of this
far-left progressive commentator she did
the same thing she said look at these
bigoted white women who Oded 59% for Ted
Cruz so let's get this straight let's
get this straight
ninety-five percent of black women voted
for bata o'rourke in Texas 59% of white
women voted for Ted Cruz but white women
are indoctrinated to vote along
intersectionally racist lines black
women are just voting their conscience
why don't we just suggest that everyone
is kind of voting for whom they want to
vote for and it's free country so who
cares but that's not how the left thing
so the next target of their
intersectional rage will be white women
which means that the gender gap may
actually come down like good strategy
her Democrats go for that do that make
sure that you attack one of the one of
the major demographic groups in the
United States attack white men attack
white women the total of which comprises
68 percent of the American population
attack those people see how that goes
for you see if that's gonna work out
well for you it's amazing it's like both
sides want to lose the suburbs seriously
like Donald Trump will not spend five
minutes reaching out to the suburbs and
so he gets swamped in the suburbs and
meanwhile the far-left progressive
Democrats are telling white women if
there are a bunch of gender traitors so
it's like everyone is just slapping
around the suburbs and the suburbs have
to decide whether they're going to move
with the progressive left or they're
gonna move with Donald Trump I swear if
somebody were to just shake hands with
anyone in the suburbs they would win the
suburbs now you know it gets this
cocaine Mitch gets this so cocaine Mitch
who has proved himself to be one of the
most
a political operators of our time the
Senate Majority Leader talking dana
perino yesterday he says listen we gotta
reach out to the suburbs is what I was
saying yesterday if Republicans want to
win suburbia is where they're going to
do it and that means they need to remake
those connections what we did we
definitely need to stop the slide we
used to do much better in the suburbs
across America than we're doing now
we're happy about the gains that we've
made in rural America which didn't used
to be totally Republican like it seems
to be now right but we ought to be able
to do both we ought to be able to appeal
to our rural and small-town constituents
and do a better job than we did Tuesday
in the suburb ok so Mitch McConnell gets
it if Republicans want to win then they
will listen to Mitch McConnell because
Mitch McConnell if he's proved anything
that's dude is a survivor and his Senate
majority grew last the other night so
again yeah I think that let's not be
distracted by it by all of the the
battles between the media and Trump
let's not be distracted even by all of
the smaller stuff let's focus on what
really matters and that is the lives of
people across the United States if the
Republicans focus on that I think that
they win big in 2020 if they don't I
think they lose big in 2020 it is pretty
much that simple okay time for things I
like and then things that I hate so
things that I like I have to admit that
I always enjoy enjoy Michael Moore's
political analysis he came out yesterday
and he said that President Trump is an
evil genius it's always fun to watch
Michael Moore pump up President Trump
and and you know the election night was
no different but I mean it's the the man
is a genius in this area he's an evil
genius but to not respect how smart he's
been in doing this okay say he's an evil
genius president Trump I do love that
this is the Democrats Kansas side
whether he's an evil genius or mother
he's a dunce the real answer as I've
said before is that President Trump is a
stand-in for generic Republican and
people don't like Democrats right now
that's that's pretty much what's
happening here the only area in which
President Trump he's good at two things
he's good at driving out the base he
gets full credit for that and he's good
at driving out the opposition space gets
full credit for that too
those are the two things that he is
really good at okay other things that I
like I'm never gonna be on the view I've
just I've given up on that dream in life
you know not many dreams in my life that
I've had to give up on but that one I've
had to give up on well I wish that
we're on the view because I would like
to ask questions I have so many
questions about the view
so Joy Behar over on ABC she said that
Republicans won the Senate because of
gerrymandering she is a quote unquote
political analyst on a mainstream
television show and she thought that
Senate Senate seats could be
gerrymandered that's not how the Senate
works they're just States
you can't gerrymander a state it's not
like the state of Iowa just gerrymanders
into Chicago they pick up a few extra
votes that's not that's not how this
works so well done everyone on failing
basic civics everyone seems to be doing
a fantastic job okay time for a quick
thing that I hate I wasn't sure whether
to put this in things I like or things I
hate but it is a hilarious story so this
is according to the UK Telegraph a
pensioner in in this looks like a
pensioner in Denmark he has begun a
legal battle to be recognized as being
twenty years younger than his actual age
so he can go back to work and achieve
greater success with women on tinder his
name is Emil rattle bond is 69 he argues
that if transgender people are allowed
to change sex he should be allowed to
change his date of birth because doctor
said he has the body of a 45 year old
this guy not all heroes wear capes I
mean just big tacular so the
entrepreneur and self-help guru is suing
his local authority after they refused
to amend his age on official documents
his case is now gone to a court in the
city of our iron men in the Eastern
Dutch province of Gelderland the cases
caused controversy in his homeland where
the Dutch edition of ice and news weigh
a news website asked is Emil Rachel bond
disturbed or accidentally extremely woke
and that would be the question right
because they are the same thing being
extremely woke and being disturbed
now the crossover like if you had a Venn
diagram of extremely woke and disturbed
the Venn diagram is just a circle
okay mr. rattle bond was born on March
11 1949 he says he feels at least 20
years younger he wants to change his
birthday - March 11th 1969
he says I've done the checkup what does
it show my biological age is 45 years
but I'm 69 I'm limited if I'm 49 I can
buy a new house drive a different car I
can take up more work when I'm on tinder
and I say I'm 69 I don't get an answer
when I'm 49 with the face I have I will
be in a luxurious position so
transgenders can now have their gender
changed on their birth certificate and
the same spirit there should be room for
an age change okay there are some of us
there are some of us who actually made
this use this as an example use this as
an example of why transgenderism is bad
logic in fact there are videos that some
of us have cut with like 70 million
views in which we asked this exact
question so good for this guy because I
love it the court said there would be
practical problems this is so good okay
so the judge said he had some sympathy
with mr. rattle ban as people could now
change their gender which whatever one's
been unthinkable but the court said
there be practical problems and allowing
people to change their birthday as it
would mean legally deleting part of
their lives oh you mean like legally
deleting the part of your life where you
were biologically male as in your entire
life if you're a transgender female or
illegally deleting even the part of your
life where you identified as a member of
the other gender the judge asked mr.
rattled man about the status of his
early years from 1949 to 1969 if his
official birth date was put back said
for whom did your parents care in those
years who is that little boy back then
the judge asked the court is going to
deliver a ruling on it and the answer is
who cares right that's the it shouldn't
that be the woke answer the woke answer
is who cares your parents cared for it
we're just rewriting history now so if
you were a little boy growing up and now
you think that you are a woman we're
your parents caring for a little boy no
because we can change your birth
certificate so they're apparently caring
for a little girl you were always a
little girl so if you say that you are
actually 20 years younger than you are
then your parents were caring for
nothing you didn't exist it's all a
figment of the imagination I love this
story so much I should put it in things
I like it's just I've decided it is it
is too wonderful in every possible
respect just spectacular stuff so um
good good good on that Dutch man for for
being so woke okay well we will be back
here tomorrow with all of the latest
tomorrow is a Friday man this week has
been eight weeks long we'll be back here
tomorrow with the mailbag now is a good
time to subscribe if you want to ask
questions
because then you can have your questions
answered if not then you'll suffer the
pangs of envy for all the others who got
to ask questions so go to daily where
comment subscribe i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing